hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
what was the greatest game on the
original PlayStation now's the time to
think about it as retro gaming has had
such an impact on the world thanks to
both the NES and SNES minis released by
nintendo over the last few years that
now 24 years after its inception Sony
are bringing back the og PlayStation 4
the retro nostalgia in December 2018
just before the Christmas rush we can
get our hands on the PlayStation classic
retailing at just under $100 in the u.s.
90 pounds here in the UK and 100 euros
in the rest of Europe the PlayStation
Classic will arrive with 20 games
pre-installed and ready to play
instantly we only know five of them at
present as you know Sony they want to
extend all the hype all the way up to
the launch just before Christmas on
December the 3rd so far the games
confirmed are the exquisite Final
Fantasy 7 one of the greatest fighters
in history Tekken 3 a solid racer in
Ridge Racer type 4 a western themed RPG
Wild Arms and the first-person
platformer known as jumping flash it
looks like Sony have released a wide
range of genres so even at this early
stage there should be something for
everyone but there are still 15 games to
be revealed so here's the question what
games do you need to be on the
PlayStation Classic for me I would love
to play Metal Gear Solid that's perfect
little bugger smash the parameters of
gaming and change the video game culture
forever letters replay it please Konami
please Sony before I go off on a tangent
let's quickly go through the hardware we
receive for our money the console runs
through HDMI so no need to faff around
with cables older than most of your
family its plug in and play the output
is 720p which is a huge upgrade from the
90s but a little lower than you're used
to on your ps4 it can also output in
480p which should feel a little bit more
old-school for those that want it the
mini console comes with two controllers
perfect for some co-op gameplay are some
Tekken button bashing the PlayStation
classic follows on from the Nintendo
minis and by mini we mean 45% smaller
than its bigger brother
going back to the controllers for a
moment notice that they are the original
versions from before the analog sticks
were added this is to keep the console
as original as possible but it also
keeps the costs down and could also hint
at the games that may be coming soon
games like resident evil were created
for the d-pad but the Dual Shock version
was released with analog stick support I
expect the remaining 15 games to be from
Playstations early life cycle the games
that come to mind are Tomb Raider maybe
Resident Evil 2 Tony Hawk Castlevania
parappa the rapper Crash Bandicoot WWF
know your role down in that game was
bloody awesome the problem with many of
those games are the remastered or the
updated versions which are flooding the
market and publishers may not want the
additional competition we'll just have
to wait and see
so are you grabbing one I personally
can't wait if you follow me on Twitter
you know that my 4 year old is currently
being schooled on the history of video
games and has just finished Super Mario
World on the SNES mini the PlayStation
Classic will be the next step in his
gaming education so I'll leave you with
that question what was the greatest game
ever released on the PlayStation I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
an absolute pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]
Metal Gear Solid was the best game ever